Speaker 1: So David Litt is a former Barack
Obama speechwriter.
I've interviewed him on the program.
Really interesting guy to talk to you.
You can check out the YouTube archives or
the website archives to find my interview
with David David.
It was invited to Newsmax yesterday, presumably
to talk about Elon Musk's hosting of Saturday
Night Live on Saturday evening.
And it went very similarly to the Fox News
clip we looked at earlier of Randi Weingarten
calling out Fox News while on Fox News.
David Litt went on Newsmax and he called them
out because of their deceptive and outrageous
coverage of the twenty twenty election.
And I have to tell you, this was done so expertly
and it starts so subtly, it's introduced so
smoothly that it actually takes a second for
the Newsmax host to even realize what's going
on.
David Litt says, yeah, you know, Saturday
Night Live, they wrote stuff that wasn't true
and they said it to their audience in comedy
format, of course.
And that's what Newsmax did with the 2020
election coverage over the last several months.
It just wasn't comedy.
And this is how it went.
Speaker 2: This one.
David Lynch, good morning.
Welcome to Wake Up America.
Nice to see you.
Thanks for having me.
I did not watch Saturday Night Live.
I watched the clips, the shows on too late.
Quite frankly, I don't think it's that funny
anymore.
What do you think of Elon Musk's performance?
This is the first time since twenty fifteen.
We've had a non athlete, non entertainer on
the show.
The last person to do that and do well with
great ratings, our former president, Donald
Trump.
Speaker 1: Well, Rob, it's a great question.
I mean, what happened on SNL this weekend
was that people
Speaker 6: made stuff up and then set it on
television like it's true.
And that actually happens pretty frequently
in American TV.
For example, in 2020,
Speaker 1: Dominion voting system sued Newsmax
over its false claims about election fraud.
Newsmax was lying to its own viewers and Newsmax
had to settle that lawsuit.
So actually, I just need to check in.
Are you still telling that lie or are
Speaker 6: you telling new lies?
Speaker 2: What are we talking about?
I'm sorry, David.
Are we talking about do you want to talk about
something completely unrelated and try to
catch me on a Monday morning totally off topic?
Or do you want to talk about Elon Musk?
Speaker 1: I just love the reference from
the host to Monday morning.
David Litt, you know, on a Tuesday afternoon,
this would be acceptable.
How dare you try this on me on a Monday morning?
And this is actually something that's done
really frequently.
When a host is pushed up against the wall
or made uncomfortable, they often will go
back to this isn't what we booked you to talk
about.
I've sometimes done this as a guest, sometimes
guests.
When the guest is sandbagged, the guest will
say, you didn't book me to talk about this
and it's a rhetorical crutch.
You just have to be prepared for how to handle
it.
Unless you've agreed not to talk about something,
you just have to be prepared as the host or
as the guest.
I've had situations.
We've had maybe two or three situations where
a guest or their publicist will say, listen,
please don't ask about X because there's ongoing
litigation, just can't comment on it.
And it's going to bring the interview to a
halt.
And of course, I have the option as the host
of saying, well, I will ask about it, but
the guest can say I'm not able to to talk
about that right now, or it might not even
really be a central topic.
And I would say, oh, yeah, that's not the
topic of the interview.
Anyway, I've been on shows where they give
me a list of eight topics and say we might
talk about these things.
And I have said before, I don't know anything
about topic number five, so I'd rather not
talk about it.
If you ask me, I'll just say I don't know
about that.
So I'm not the right person to ask.
And we sort of come to an agreement.
Other than that, it's basically just a rhetorical
game.
And sometimes when a guest will turn around
and start asking the host questions, the host
will do the I'm asking the questions here.
You're here as my guest.
And then it's just sort of like a battle of
rhetoric.
There's no, like, set rules about this.
It's really up for interpretation.
And here the host really comes off like a
loser, quite frankly.
Let's continue.
Well, I can see why you don't want to talk
about Dominion voting systems, because if
you do, Newsmax could get sued and lose billions
of dollars because these are lot.
David.
Speaker 2: David.
David, David.
That's lesson David.
That's fine.
David, I know this is a very funny moment
for you.
I'm sure you didn't sleep last night as you
prepared to sort of try and get the morning
anchor on Newsmax.
I'd be happy to talk with you about whatever
you want to talk about.
Obviously, it's not the topic that we have
set up for right now.
So if you'd like to talk about Saturday Night
Live, I will do that with you.
But obviously, I'm not going to talk about
anything else right now.
So you decide right now in this moment on
live television.
Go ahead.
Speaker 1: The Dominion voting systems have
any impact on the 2020 election.
Speaker 2: Oh, that's unfortunate because
I was really excited about this interview,
I didn't watch SNL on Saturday night, but
I thought Elon Musk did an OK job and he also
said that he's got Asperger's.
So I thought that was a fascinating component
of the monologue.
So, David, we look forward to having him back
on very soon again.
That was a stellar interview.
David, let thanks so much for joining us.
We'll be right back.
Speaker 1: So, yeah, just cutting off the
interview.
And it reminds me, by the way, the mention
of Asperger's or as the host says, Asperger's,
there's a reason we no longer say Asperger's
and instead say, you know, high functioning
autism or low, low severity autism spectrum
disorder.
Dr. Hans Asperger did work linked to Naziism,
Nazi child psychiatry.
There's a debate because Asperger himself,
I guess, was a resister, a Nazi resister to
the Nazis.
But many children that were identified by
him as having so-called Asperger's were subsequently
killed by Nazis.
So I was actually surprised that Elon Musk
even used that term to describe his own condition.
Maybe that's a topic for another day.
I like what David did here.
It did get cut off pretty quickly, but there's
really no other way to pierce the Newsmax
filter bubble because otherwise, you know,
you can talk about Newsmax on other channels,
but going on Newsmax and doing it there, I
think it's fantastic.
I loved it.
For me, it's perfect for a Monday morning.
Monday morning is like the perfect day to
do what David did.
And quite frankly, it was kind of funnier
than a lot of recent Saturday Night Live skits.
I've not been super impressed with SNL recently.
Nice job by David Litt.
And hopefully we'll have more of these upcoming